Oh,
you,
where do you like going to Russia so much?
I do.
I do enjoy it up there.
Yeah,
I do.
I use a lot of time.
Let me say,
um,
well I like 'em.
I like traveling,
so this is a cool thing.
I've got to travel so much.
I've got to see a lot of really cool places and uh,
uh,
Russia's one of them.
I like all the different places I've been there.
Saint Peters of course,
cause Russian.
One thing is it's like America,
lots of different places.
Wherever you are.
Like,
you know,
this America to some people could seem like a different country,
different states that Jewish summer.
Yeah.
So it's like that.
So,
um,
I got to,
uh,
I go to Moscow.
Moscow's one thing,
you know,
you get to,
there's a lot of history,
a lot of Nice things to see.
Saint Petersburg,
same thing.
Um,
do you feel safe when you're over there?
Well,
I take everything at face value so that,
that's the way I go through life.
Because if I was to try to always read some undercurrents or read what,
uh,
people tell me I'm supposed to experience,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm never gonna do anything like,
um,
a long time ago,
my troubles,
my,
um,
I was going to go do one of butter being shown down in Alabama and my parents
were like,
man,
you're going to Alabama,
be safe down there.
Don't be doing all that stuff you do.
You know,
it's going to be different because of,
you know,
American,
our history with racism.
And,
uh,
I went down there and I was,
you know,
this is [inaudible],
it's a,
you might have to tell the story because this is the story.
So I went down there,
I was,
I was at the show.
And then some,
uh,
cops come up and they look like the cops from,
you know,
in the movies from the south that you're supposed to scare you.
And I took a picture with them and they're like,
and somebody else came to take a picture and they're like,
oh,
look what we started going,
Oh man,
I'm going to do this on this one.
I'm here to do.
I mean,
hanging out with people.
I remember referee fights and you know,
talk to people they want to talk.
So I took a lot of pictures.
They were impressed.
They're saying that,
you know,
they've seen other people,
tell people know about pictures and the guy all sided,
they're like,
hey,
um,
we want you to come out and pull people over with this.
I'm like,
no,
I don't want to do,
I have no interest in doing that.
You know,
I grew up in La,
you know what I mean?
Like they're like,
and they're getting pumped.
They're like,
imagine like you're getting pulled over by herb dean pitch.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I'm like,
no,
I don't want to do it.
And uh,
then one goes out,
he goes,
well,
well some do some,
I mean,
want to make this,
do some tase me or something hurting.
So like he grabs this,
his taser gun and sticks the Taser in my hand.
She's,
and I'm sitting there and I'm like,
what the fuck?
So I started tasing him,
right.
I'm changing,
this isn't this guy.
And he's like,
I'm like a,
I'm,
so then,
um,
I,
after the tasing,
uh,
his buddy,
one of the,
um,
agents,
one of the guys who's working with me comes up and tells him that he has some
business to talk about with me.
I go,
wait,
what'd you want to talk about?
It goes,
man,
I could see her so uncomfortable with what was going on that I just go with the,
I was like,
thanks.
So I get back to him,
I give back to my hotel room and I,
I stinking,
I was like,
man,
you know,
I'm worried about people prejudging and being intolerant.
I'm prejudging of these guys because of uh,
some history and these guys are really cool.
If I ever get the opportunity to seize guys,
I'm going to be,
you know,
man.
And I,
and I did,
they came like right there and the phone rings,
I swear.
And they took me to an after party and they're like,
yeah,
they took it like,
it was like the place looks like roadhouse and you know what I mean?
Like everything you see like in a movie,
like,
you know some,
you know it,
your wife's not going to be happy about that and,
and I'm going to catch you next week.
One of those types of things,
right?
Yeah.
Drove me to the airport with the lights on skirts.
I think,
I think I still have the picture of me tasing him.
I could show it to you.
It was like,
it was a pretty cool experience.
So after that I was like,
man,
uh,
whatever.
I think I know about things.
I really don't.
And so,
uh,
so I took things at face value.
Yeah.
I've had good times now Obama,
I've had good times in the south.
I think the world's changing too.
I really do.
I think there's those parts of it,
especially this country,
we almost everywhere you can find.
Cool.
So,
yeah.
So I mean if,
uh,
you know,
oh my God,
that is hilarious.
So,
so that should put this on your Instagram.
Can you?
Yeah.
Can they wouldn't mind.
I've talked to those guys about it.
Don't you think he's going to get in trouble though?
No,
he's not gonna.
He said he's fine.
He said it'll be all right.
I thought we'd would get in trouble,
so I didn't want to know.
Yeah.
That's why I haven't put it on.
That's why I never did it,
but I've actually talked to him.
So anyway,
this,
um,
that,
yeah,
that's a big lesson to me.
Like,
Hey,
don't,
don't think you know what's going on,
you know,
take things at face value.
Try to beat,
you know,
yeah.